they've decided they're putting vice
president harris in charge of the border
i mean because what we definitely need
is somebody whose first reaction to
every awkward question is to cackle like
the joker
she's been put in charge of the border
they said this a week ago she's not gone
down to the border so far as i'm aware
nor has she actually given a press
conference on the border so far
somewhere but
she did speak to the hispanic chamber of
commerce and say that help is here
she said quad way or something here is a
vp harris
this past year it's been difficult
both for your bottom line and for your
peace of mind
one in four small businesses have closed
thousands
owned by latinos these numbers reinforce
what we already know the situation is
urgent
when the president and i were preparing
to take office
he promised that help is on its way
well now help is here um
help is here is it well i'm noticing on
the border there are some people who
seem disproportionately hispanic and
origin and the help isn't there
as it turns out it turns out that in
some of these facilities you're holding
people
at like a thousand percent of capacity
so
you haven't been down there every time
you get asked a question you just start
cackling
like a crazy person but help is
here or something well the good news is
we will always have stalwart fighters
for the people at the border their human
rights store fighters
like alexander ocasio-cortez now let's
be real about this
she is just a breath of fresh air she is
she is
so fresh so face i mean not just a fresh
face
so fresh and so faced alexandra
ocasio-cortez in fact she is so fresh
and so faced that she brought her super
fresh superface
all the way down to the border you'll
remember during the trump administration
where in a totally spontaneous
non-planned
public relations act she ended up at a
fence
in front of a parking lot that was a
ways away from border facility
and there she broke down in a pure
display
of unbridled compassion and emotion in
which she stared directly into camera
for some reason while wearing a
perfectly
white outfit because feminist power
and you remember is these these amazing
pictures of just the incredible emotion
on display when she saw the cruelty
the malevolence the malice the brutality
of the trump administration and their
treatment of illegal immigrants
at the border holding kids in cages and
she couldn't take it anymore and she
went down there
and like sarah connor in terminator 2 in
the dream sequence she put her hands in
the chain-link fence
and she screamed to the heavens why oh
god
why would you allow such evil to take
place
on this planet and in this country why
well now joe biden is holding like a
multiple
of that number of kids in cages and
they're
like packed together in the middle of a
coveted pandemic and
aoc has not been down to the border
probably she just hasn't had time or
something
she's super sincere and brilliant she
she probably just hasn't had time to be
down
at the border or maybe that white outfit
is still at the dry cleaners i mean it's
been like a couple of years but it's not
a great dry cleaners to be honest with
you
and and maybe that photographer was i
don't know like
booked okay but she hasn't been down to
the border or anything
but she did have time to do an insta
she did insta and when she did her insta
she discussed what is happening on the
border and let me just say
the pearls of wisdom floweth like water
from that so fresh so face a few decades
ago private citizens it used to be
largely that private
what has changed interwebs think about
everything you browse search for watched
tweeted now imagine
all of that data being crawled through
and collected and aggregated by third
parties into a permanent
public record your record to keep my
data private when i go online
i turn to expressvpn here's how it works
it's super simple
all you have to do is go to your cell
phone right now it says not connected
boom i hit connected
connecting connecting connecting
connecting connecting done data
harvesters will use your ip
to uniquely identify you and your
location with expressvpn
however my connection gets rerouted to
an encrypted server my ip address is
masked and anonymized every time i turn
expressvpn on
i'm given a random ip address shared by
other expressvpn customers
and makes it tougher for third parties
to identify me and harvest my data if
like me you believe your data is your
business secure yourself with the number
one rated vpn on the market visit
expressvpn.com
get three extra months for free that's
expr essvpn.com
go to expressvpn.com to learn more
heroes aoc talking about the border
crisis
and saying some of the most
intellectually
incisive things i have ever heard about
the border
it's like when einstein i'm sure would
give a disquisition
on the physics of relativity that's like
aoc on border policy
except einstein was up was a
just i mean like she is just the amount
of intellectual firepower here
it's it's pretty astonishing i i will
say that here she was
really sounding off yeah in emotional
fashion about what's happening
under president biden at the border
where again a multiple of children are
now being held
and we're ever held under under trump
often people want to say
why are you talking about the border
crisis or why aren't you talking about
it in this way
well we're talking about it they just
don't like how we're talking about it
because it's not a border crisis it's an
imperialism crisis it's a climate crisis
it's a trade crisis
anyone who's using the term surge around
you
consciously is trying to invoke a
militaristic frame
and that's a problem because
these this is not a surge these are
children and they are not insurgents
and we are not being invaded
deep thoughts mind-blown i mean it is
it's not a border crisis guys it's an
imperialism crisis don't you see
it's because america invaded these
central and latin american nations and
all these people
they didn't cross the border that bore
across them or alternatively they
crossed the border illegally but
it's an imperialism crisis also it's a
climate crisis
sure it's not a climate crisis sure
you're blaming all the sun a hurricane
that happened like months and months and
months ago and then the search started
and the surge happened like way after
the hurricane but it's a climate crisis
guys it is not a policy crisis there is
no crisis on the border it's a figment
of your imagination
you know how i know because if it were a
crisis on the border she'd be down there
in a white outfit
crying at the border that's how you know
i don't have to watch the news
i don't have to take i don't have to pay
attention to any of the stats all i have
to do
is watch whether aoc is taking an
emotionally overweight photo at the
border to tell whether we have a climate
crisis or a border crisis
and she says no border crisis i believe
her no border crisis guys
it is not a border crisis it is an
imperialism crisis it's a climate crisis
and it is a trade crisis
because the balance of trade is off or
there aren't
tariffs or something i know that when we
have a trade dispute with canada we
immediately get
a huge surge of canadians just coming
over that northern border
happens all the time we've been having
this massive trade standoff with the
chinese government and that's what we've
been getting it's just an enormous
number of chinese expatriates just
leaving just right there on the border
amazing
because that's how trade policy works
guys it's incredible
also surge don't use the word surge
never use the word sergeant
i can't do it don't use the word surge
because if you use the word surge you
are invoking
insurge ins you see she put a prefix
and a suffix you put in and ins
before and after the word surge and boom
you're using a militaristic frame
when you say there's a surge normally
this is what i think like
when let's say the lights go out in my
house right and i think oh my gosh maybe
there was a power surge
i'm using a militaristic frame because
what i really mean is that my
electricity
is a guerrilla force it is an insurgent
force
when i put a surge protector into the
wall to stop that sort of thing from
happening
that's because i'm an imperialist and
i'm attempting to stop those guerrilla
insurgent electrics
from invading my toaster surge insurgent
same thing same thing you see here's the
thing she knows the deep etymology of
these words she understands that both
words actually do come
from the latin word for rise this is
true that's what she knows
she knows that and she knows that when
you say there's a surge of people at the
border
what you mean you bastard what you mean
is that children are like terrorist
militants
also she knows that not only does surge
mean that
follow the logic here okay when you say
surge
what you really mean is that one one
time you knew an eastern european guy
named serge and serge
was not the best guy serge was the kind
of guy who wouldn't pick you up at the
airport
and that made you think of insurgents so
when you said surge you meant that guy
surge who's a bad guy
and also made you think of insurgents
and so you are just slamming all that
together to rip on the children and
that's the problem here
these people you want these people in
charge
that's what you want these ones
these ones seriously
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content